so last night the President of the
United States gave his very first
official State of the Union address and
it was shall we say huge we'll go
through all of it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
we had a lot of fun last night here at
the Daily wire we did a full on state of
the union watch party and Trump given
pretty good speech and we all had a lot
of fun well I had less fun than the
other so they're all smoking cigars I'm
not a cigar smoking smoker and so I got
to inhale their secondhand smoke all
evening long yet nonetheless a good time
was had by all you can go and view that
entire thing over at Facebook I believe
we did it at YouTube as well you can
check that out or you can download it
because I think that it's available on
our podcast stream as well so we'll get
to everything Trump relate we'll get to
the State of the Union what happened the
blowback the responses from Joe Kennedy
the third you know that that great scion
of the Kennedy family as well as Bernie
Sanders his response the media losing
their might we'll go over all of it but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at tracker so I got up
this morning and you know what I
couldn't find my keys but it wasn't a
problem because I just went to my phone
and then I opened up my tracker app I
hit a button and boom like he started
ringing right at me the reason this is
so great is because every day you do the
same thing but you don't have the
tracker app do you and that is why
you've been searching for the last half
an hour's while listening to my podcast
for your keys and now you're gonna miss
your important meeting you don't have to
be that guy
instead go over to tracker and make sure
that you get their new tracker pixel
it's the lightest Bluetooth tracking
device on the market you put the tracker
pixel on whatever you tend to lose keys
wallet purse it is small enough to fit
anywhere when you misplace an item that
has a tracker pixel attached you can use
your smartphone and a 90 decibel alert
will help you find it in seconds it even
has powerful LED lights so you can find
anything even in the dark also if you
lose your phone and you left the ringer
off one of the beautiful things about
tracker you got your keys hit that
button and boom your phone's gonna ring
right at you even though you left the
ringer off so you never have to lose
your phone your wallet your keys ever
ever again and they have a 30-day
money-back guarantee which means you
have nothing to lose save 20% off your
order when you go to the tracker comm
slash Ben that's the track are.com slash
Ben for 20% off again the tracker comm
slash Ben make your life a lot easier
it's one of those the inconveniences you
don't think about but one you never have
to think about it again you realize you
just saved a lot of time in your life
that that you will want back so the
tracker comm slash Ben you get 20% off
okay so last night president Trump gives
his big first official state of the
universe when I say big I mean it was
huge when I say it was you too
it was long like super long like it just
ended five minutes before the show it
was really really long it was an hour
and twenty minutes or so
it was the third longest State of the
Union address ever recorded it you know
in terms of number of words it wasn't
quite that long but Trump's cadence is
relatively slow it was also quite
successful so the poll numbers show
according to CBS News poll seventy five
percent of Americans thought that this
speech was good seventy five percent of
Americans thought this speech was
unifying fully 43 percent of Democrats
thought the speech was good according to
the the CBS News poll 91 percent favored
what they heard on infrastructure
eighty-one percent said that the
president was uniting the country 75
percent approved through the speech 75
percent favored what they heard on
national security and 72 percent favored
what they heard on immigration that by
any measure is a is a massive success
for the President of the United States
we're gonna go through this because
there are really two aspects to that
three aspects I think to the Trump
speech that are noteworthy one is the
good one is the bad and one is the ugly
okay the good is a lot of what Trump did
here he did some great storytelling
whoever wrote the speech did a great job
of getting sympathetic victims in the
stands everybody does the Ronald Reagan
stick where you get a bunch of people
who sit up there in the rafters and then
you say and there's Bob Bob's the great
American hand for Bob and everybody
collapsed well that's been misused for
years and years Trump did it right last
night we'll talk about all the things
from tonight we'll also talk about the
Democrats response because the Democrats
apparently had superglue attached to
their asses they literally did not get
up for the entire speech I mean even on
things where they agree even on things
like black unemployment is down and
everybody's cheering and then you look
over and the Congressional Black Caucus
is sitting it's like what are you
against black people working what's your
problem
there were times during the speech where
Trump was saying things like we all
stand for the American flag and you look
over all the Democrats you're sitting a
Nancy Pelosi is chewing under dentures
and they're thinking is this really your
strategy so we'll talk about the
Democratic strategy here because it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense they
basically define themselves as the
anti-trump party as opposed to even the
progressive party at this point even
things they agree with they will boycott
if Trump is involved with them and then
there was the the snows the ugly and
then there was the bad the bad was Trump
didn't say word one it really was stuff
Trump didn't say so Trump did not talk
at all about fiscal responsibility in
the speech because Trump is not a
fiscally responsible guy
HM doesn't care about deficits he
doesn't care about debts he's more like
George W Bush than he is like Ronald
Reagan on that score he's certainly more
like either of those than he's like
Calvin Coolidge he's not somebody who
deeply cares about entitlements running
out of control he said this during the
campaign so he's been pretty obvious
about the idea he doesn't mean to tamp
down spending he said in the speech that
Obamacare is basically dead which it
isn't
he suggested in the speech that he
wanted to blow out the spending on
infrastructure to the tune of 1.5
trillion dollars which is not a
conservative policy he said he wanted
paid parental and family leave that is
not a conservative policy either he
didn't say one word about reducing the
federal deficit or the federal debt
that's because that's tough political
stuff and Trump doesn't want to touch
all that stuff so that's the that's the
bad stuff but we'll go through it a
little bit more in detail so last night
Trump walks out and pretty much
everybody stands and claps there there
are some Democrats particularly members
of the CBC who will stand and clap for
Louis Farrakhan but they won't stand and
clap for the elected presidents of the
United States Trump walks out and and he
takes the stage and the first thing he
does is he lays out the fact that he's
had a very good economic first year
here's what he had to say since the
election we have created 2.4 million new
jobs including 200,000 new jobs in
manufacturing alone after years and
years of wage stagnation we are finally
seeing rising wages unemployment claims
have hit a 45 year low african-american
unemployment stands at the lowest rate
ever recorded the Democrats and there
they are right every Democrat is sitting
black people working no Trump's evil and
then Trump continues and he's talking
about the economy a little bit more one
of the things that I think was really
fascinating about what he said here is
he actually makes a case that was not
made during the tax cut debate is why
the polls were bad on the tax cuts if
you look at the actual poll numbers on
the tax cuts the poll numbers suggested
that most Americans thought they were
losing money on the tax cuts which of
course was not true nearly everybody
gets money back thanks to the tax cuts
that's because the Republicans had
failed to actually talk about what the
tax bill would do for the average
American family they're talking about
about what tax cuts do generally Trump
did a good job I think of summing that
up last night typical family of four
making seventy five thousand dollars
will see their tax bill reduced by two
thousand dollars slashing their tax bill
in half in April this will be the last
time you will ever file under the old
and very broken system and millions of
Americans will have more take-home pay
starting next month we eliminated an
especially cruel tax that fell mostly on
Americans making less than $50,000 a
year forcing them to pay tremendous
penalties simply because they couldn't
afford government ordered health plans
we repealed the core of the disastrous
Obamacare the individual mandate is now
gone right so this is all good stuff
that the American people have to hear
because the media have been making a
corrupt an untrue case that tax cuts
hurt the American economy and that
repeal of Obama cares individual mandate
is going to kill millions of Americans
and all the rest of all of this and from
anding forcefully spoke back against
this now the bad side of this is when
Trump says the core of the disastrous
Obama care is gone what that suggests is
he's not gonna do anything else on Obama
care that basically he thinks his work
is done here
that of course is untrue but this is
good stuff from the president and then
the president says something that I
think a lot of Republicans have not been
saying which is when you lower the
corporate tax rate you are going to make
more money and the proof is in the
pudding when we quote when we lower the
corporate tax rate jobs come back to the
United States and not only the jobs come
back you're probably gonna get a raise
so here's what Trump had to say about
that we slashed the business tax rate
from 35% all the way down to 21% so
American companies can compete and win
against anyone else anywhere in the
world these changes alone are estimated
to increase average family income by
more than $4,000 right that last
statistic is the one that Republicans
really should have been focusing on
during the entire tax debate is why is
it that when we lower corporate tax
rates
people's income goes up instead they
focused on the individual
rates dropping they should have been
focusing on the really major change to
the law which was that major reduction
in corporate tax rates and it was a
major reduction in corporate tax rate so
Trump starts off and this is a full 20
minutes on the economy which is exactly
what he should do these if Trump is
gonna win reelection if Republicans are
not going to get shellacked in 2018
there has to be a feeling that the
economy is on the move
and it's on the move because Republicans
have done the right things and the truth
is it is on the move because of that you
know that the economy was already
improving under President Obama
obviously the stock market was up under
President Obama job growth in 2016 was
better than job growth in 2017 by a
couple hundred thousand jobs but the
reason that wages are rising the reason
why businesses are hiring the reason
people feel the sense of optimism is
because there's a sense of trust that
the Republicans and Trump are not going
to clock businesses in the back of the
head there's always the feeling with
Democrats and with Obama that from some
angle he was gonna find a way to hit
businesses because he didn't like
businesses you don't get that feeling
with Trump and that came out last night
okay so I want to talk in a minute about
some of the more dramatic moments of the
Trump speech because there were some
really there there are some moments of
tremendous drama in the Trump speech
will continue going through the State of
the Union in just a second first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
blinka so you are an information addict
it's why you listen to this show we
provide more information than anyone
else in the business but if you love
information you need to supplement your
informational diet even more and that's
what blink astiz for blink is just for
the person who has six meetings a day
and you're only in the car for 15
minutes how you gonna get more
information well the way you're gonna
get more information is through the
bling kissed app so what it does it
boils down best-selling non-fiction
books into what they call blinks these
sort of summaries of the main points of
the book so you can read four books in
an hour right you're in the car for an
hour you get four 15-minute blinks and
suddenly you know the main points of 600
page books over two thousand of the
best-selling non-fiction books
transformed into these powerful packs
you can listen to in just 15 minutes
so you can get through two to three
books a day if you want right blinka
says the special offer just for our
audience go to blinka stay calm slash
Ben right now you start your free trial
you get three months off your yearly
plan when you join today so that's blink
is calm be li NK is T blink astute comm
slash Ben to start your free trial or
again get three months off your yearly
plan blink is calm / Ben really is a
tremendous app everybody I know who's
tried it loves it I use it it's really
great has
books that I've enjoyed like I'm
actually read the entire book and what
do I remember about the book probably
not 15 minutes worth of material because
any time you read a book your brain sort
of sift to what things belonged they do
the work for you over a blanket books
like drive and Rich Dad Poor Dad and how
to start worrying and start Olivia I
mean these are all great books and you
can get them all at blink Escom slash
Ben so check that out and especially
because you get a special discount again
you got a free trial or three months off
your yearly plan when you joined today
okay so back to president Trump's State
of the Union address which went over
like gangbusters so one of the things
that Trump does and he's always talked
about doing this and he actually did it
well last night is he always said that
America needs a cheerleader when people
said what does the president need to do
you say America needs to cheerleader now
listen the president has to do more than
that obviously but one of the things
that I think Trump does have the
capacity to unify on is he does have a
gut level sense of nationalistic
patriotism right the guy does like the
flag he does like the military he does
like the country he doesn't feel bad
about America you always got the sense
from President Obama that he was more
concerned with the flaws in America's
thought in America's thought patterns
and in the American people than in the
glories of them last night Trumpton
spent any time lecturing Americans about
the better angels of their nature about
this is not who we are this kind of
stuff instead President Trump talked
about the wonderful things about it was
a much more optimistic speech than
Obama's this is one of the great things
about how the media has covered this the
media said it was a dark speech this
speech was significantly more optimistic
about the state of the United States and
anything Obama ever said Obama would
always say the state of our union is
strong and then he would proceed to list
off all of the racial problems that we
had in the United States and
discrimination against women and how
America was still a backwards racist
bigoted homophobic country and how we
all had to fix that Trump last night got
up there he said listen
America is pretty awesome it's pretty
awesome and now's the time for you to
make something yourself in this clip for
so Trump really cheerleading America and
of course Democrats hitting this in fact
is our new American moment there has
never been a better time to start living
the American dream so to every citizen
watching at home tonight no matter where
you've been or where you've come from
this is your time if you work hard if
you believe in yourself if you believe
in America then you can dream anything
you can be anything and together we can
achieve absolutely anything okay and
everybody cheers except for the
Democrats right the Democrats won't
cheer for you can achieve anything here
because they hate Trump so much and it
went even further than that so Trump
calls on this young kid Preston who's
sitting in the in the family box for for
Trump speech and this kid apparently has
helped plant helped put down something
like 40,000 American flags on the graves
of fallen service members and Trump says
this and watches the Democrats it young
Patriots like Preston teach all of us
about our civic duty as America
Preston's reverence for those who have
served our nation reminds us of why we
salute our flag why we put our hands on
our hearts for the pledge of allegiance
and why we proudly stand for the
national anthem okay and he looks over
kind of concerned ly at the Democrats as
they sit there the Democrats have
painted themselves into a box this is
the problem with being both
intersectional and anti Trump so the
Democrats have a couple of problems
problem number one is that they've
decided to define their entire the
personnel the personality of their party
they've decided to define that as we
hate Trump that's not enough okay you
can just like Trump that's all well and
good but that's only gonna matter every
four years the real question is do
people have a good sense of your party
do they feel like yours is a party that
cares about the United States and when
you see Democrats sitting when you see
Democrats sitting for we proudly stand
for the national anthem because they
boxed themselves in to this idea that
it's bad to say that we should stand for
the national anthem most Americans don't
buy that most Americans don't like that
most Americans think that that's stupid
right the fact is that the Democrats are
doing this now because they've engaged
in this intersectional politics of hate
in which they suggest that if you're a
member of a minority group in the United
States then you rightly are sitting for
the national anthem or kneeling for the
national anthem I think Democrats could
have taken a middle position the middle
position would have been we like to
stand for the national anthem we think
it's dumb not to stand for the national
anthem but of course you have the right
to disagree and not stand from the
national anthem that's what they should
have said about Colin Kaepernick instead
people including Barack Obama came out
and said
there was a certain heroism to not
standing for the national anthem because
America was so cruel and so terrible
most Americans don't think America is
cruel and terrible most Americans think
America is pretty damn great you know
why because America is pretty damn great
America is pretty spectacular I have a
piece out of National Review today
talking about all the wonderful things
that we benefit from here in the United
States that even our grandparents didn't
have like things that you never think
about right your cell phone that didn't
exist ten years ago the form of cell
phone that you have the fact you're
listening to a podcast podcasting didn't
exist 10 to 15 years ago right the fact
that you that you may be watching the
sound on a computer using streaming
streaming that didn't exist 15 or 20
years ago
that's because America is in a
magnificent place the Western
civilization is a magnificent place and
that's true for people of all colors and
all sexual orientations and all
backgrounds but Democrats don't believe
that because that undermines their case
against Western civilization Trump took
full advantage of that he knew they
weren't gonna stand for the national
anthem it makes them look bad as well it
should
okay so that's one of the good things
that I think Trump did last night was
tweaking the Democrats on some of their
intersectional extremism and watching
Cory Booker sit there and make nasty
faces and Nancy Pelosi chewing her cud
well he talked about the glories of the
national anthem Trump that the pretty
pretty amazing and and and telling
visuals so then we get into a one of
trumps boo-boos of the night so well I
think that Trump's big boo-boo the night
was he was attempting to do his popular
stick by talking about how he's gonna
spend tons of money on infrastructure
again the more telling point is not that
Trump talked about infrastructure we've
had infrastructure week at last
calculation seven times I guess during
this administration where we've had
infrastructure week and then Trump tweet
something and it turns into Lavar Bal
week but he's been talking continuously
for well over a year about how he wants
to spend a ton of money on
infrastructure he says this so what a
Democrats do they said tonight I'm
calling on Congress to produce a bill
that generates at least 1.5 trillion
dollars for the new infrastructure
investment that our country so
desperately needs okay so the Democrats
don't even stand for that so now he's
talking about Democratic priorities and
they won't stand again Trump is drawing
a contrast in the contrast is really
telling the most effective portion of
the speech right the portion where
Democrats do not understand this they
refuse to understand this they are
angry that they're being forced to to
reckon with it is that most Americans
are not in favor of illegal immigration
okay we may think that a lot of illegal
immigrants came here for the right
reasons we may have sympathy for illegal
immigrants but most of us want to know
who's coming into the country and every
person who is killed by an illegal
immigrant is a person who should not
have been killed in the United States
because it is the job of the federal
government to prevent people from
entering here illegally right there are
a lot of people I'm sure who entered
gated communities not to do harm but
because they wander in or because they
just want to go for a walk okay but the
reality is if you live in a gated
community and your security doesn't do
its job and someone gets killed in your
gated community you're gonna blame the
people in charge of the gated community
America is still a gated community as it
has to be because we have a welfare
system and because we have to protect
the integrity of their voting process -
well last night President Trump did
something and he got booed by the
Democrats for doing it he pointed out
that there are in fact people who have
been victimized by illegal immigrants in
the United States and the Democrats were
saying well this is because he's a
racist in the same speech he made a
proposal to Democrats that we should let
in 1.8 million illegal immigrants allow
them to become citizens Democrats have
staff for that the heroes Donald Trump
making a particular point which is that
there are victims of criminals who come
into the United States illegally here
tonight
are two fathers and two mothers Evelyn
Rodriguez Freddie Cuevas Elisabeth
Alvarado and Robert Mickens there are
two teenage daughters Kayla Cuevas and
Nisa Mickens were close friends
on Long Island but in September 2016 on
the eve of niece's 16th birthday such a
happy time it should have been neither
of them came home these two precious
girls were brutally murdered while
walking together in their hometown six
members of the savage ms-13 gang have
been charged with Kayla and niece's
murders
many of these gang members took
advantage of glaring loopholes in our
laws to enter the country as illegal
unaccompanied alien minors and wound up
in Kayla and niece's high school Evelyn
Elizabeth Freddie and Robert tonight
everyone in this chamber is praying for
you everyone in America is grieving for
you I want you to know that 320 million
hearts are right now breaking for you
but we cannot imagine the depths of that
kind of sorrow we can make sure that
other families never have to endure this
kind of pain in Democrats of course
we're very unhappy with all this this
was Trump doing the storytelling routine
that Reagan did better than anybody I
think since Reagan nationally I think
that what Trump did here by pointing out
people in the audience not you know just
a guy who started a business but people
who have actually been victimized by bad
policy yeah I think it was tremendously
effective if you watch this and you
weren't moved by the plight of these
families if you watched them in their
heartbreak then and you didn't think
well maybe we should be able to do
something about this then I don't think
that you're watching with with an open
mind and open heart
so Trump I think did exactly the right
thing on this now in just a second we're
going to continue by talking about a
little bit more on illegal immigration a
couple more stories that Trump told
again I think he used the storytelling
art at levels that we have not seen
actually since Reagan in American
politics which is an amazing thing for
me to say cuz I don't think the Trump's
are particularly good speaker but we'll
get to all of that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so we
are only a couple of weeks into 2018
look what we have already dealt with a
false alert okay that is in in Hawaii
cyber attacks on our financial system on
the rise and we're bracing for another
tough season natural disasters and FEMA
might not be able to get there in time
well that is why you need an emergency
plan right even the local state federal
government they say you should have an
emergency plan you don't need to wait
for crisis to strike instead go out
spend a little bit of money get what you
need right now and then if disaster
strikes you're ready for it the best way
to get started is to make sure every
person in your household hasn't 102
serving emergency food kit there's just
$99 there shipped free order now call
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13
or go online to prepare with been calm
that's prepared with Ben dot-com his
emergency food the last 25 years he
spent once you don't have to worry about
it for another quarter century it's a
long time
8:03 1413 or prepare with been calm
again all the food that comes from my
Patriot supply tastes like home cooking
people in our office have tried it they
enjoyed it eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen prepare with
been calm ensure that if disaster
strikes you're ready for it prepare with
been calm okay so the President of the
United States but using his storytelling
capacity to do some serious damage to
the Democratic agenda and I think that
the most the the most polarizing and
also most successful line of his speech
last night came when he was talking
again about illegal immigration and what
he suggested is listen I have a lot of
sympathy for illegal immigrants right
people who are trying to come to this
country to make a better life for
themselves and cross the border
illegally I'm happy to legalize 1.8
million of them like today if Democrats
will make a deal but but we have to
protect American citizens first and it's
this sort of baseline route logic that
Republicans say I think most in
dependency I think even some Democrats
see but the Democratic Party refuses to
see we'll talk about that when we get to
Joe Kennedy's response because it really
is quite insipid and insane but here
tonight was a here last night was
President Trump
using language that ticked off the media
but I think most Americans heard so
tonight I am extending an open hand to
work with members of both parties
Democrats and Republicans to protect our
citizens of every background color
religion and Creed my duty and the
sacred duty of every elected official in
this chamber is to defend Americans to
protect their safety their families
their communities and their right to the
American dream because Americans are
dreamers too okay and that line got big
applause from Republicans independents
liked it Democrats didn't like it and
because Democrats didn't like it it's a
problem for them most Americans still
think that Americans ought to be taken
care of before we talk about how we take
care of foreign citizens which makes
sense this is still America now one of
the things that that was really
incredible about how Trump used
storytelling last night you know Bush
did it Obama did it they all they all do
the Reagan routine as I said of putting
people up in the rafters and then
pointing at them and saying look at this
wonderful person let's clap Trump you
know he's been using the slogan the
Forgotten men
women of the country throughout the
entire campaign and I thought that he
misused it when he talked about people
who are living in small towns and
they've lost their jobs and these are
the Forgotten men and women I'll tell
you who have been forgotten people who
believed in American values sort of
traditional American values the belief
that America is a place of Liberty
the people who make small sacrifices
that don't show up on the national scale
but who are doing the everyday work of
making America a better place and some
of the stories that are being told last
night
we're so eloquent in what they said that
they said more than the Neva what Trump
said so one example of that last night
well as he talked about the whole Lutz
family I thought this was just
magnificent is this young family where a
guy who's an officer with the
Albuquerque Police Department he tells
their story this is the most pro-life
story that you'll ever hear without
mentioning the word abortion just this
week Democrats voted down they
filibustered a bill that protects babies
in the womb after 20 weeks they've voted
that down from Donald Trump without ever
mentioning the word abortion without
ever suggesting pro life without augment
termination of pregnancy makes an
eloquent case for life by telling the
story of the helots family who are true
American heroes we see a vivid
expression of this truth in the story of
the ohlet's family of New Mexico Ryan
Hall Epps is 27 years old an officer
with the Albuquerque Police Department
he's here tonight with his wife Rebecca
last year Ryan was on duty when he saw a
pregnant homeless woman preparing to
inject heroin when Ryan told her she was
going to harm her unborn child she began
to weep she told him she didn't know
where to turn but badly wanted a safe
home for her baby in that moment Ryan
said he felt God speak to him you will
do it because you can
he took out a picture of his wife and
their four kids then he went home to
tell his wife Rebecca in an instant she
agreed to adopt the whole let's named
daughter hope Ryan and Rebecca you
embody the goodness of our nation thank
you okay I mean that is a fantastic
story too fantastic pro-life story it's
a fantastic American story it's the sort
of story that that President Obama never
would have told and when I see that as a
pro-life person it reminds me that my
priorities still matter it reminds me of
my values still matter and Trump I think
did that in us this was a rare moment of
subtlety for the president I thought it
was a great story I thought that him
bringing those those folks to the State
of the Union was terrific
and that of course was not the limit of
it he then went on to talk about North
Korea and a lot of people were saying
well what's the point of him talking
about North Korea was he building up the
case for war well not necessarily it's
quite possible that he was drawing a
contrast between North Korea in the
United States particularly in light of
the fact that Democrats keep saying over
and over that Trump is a sort of Kim
jong-un figure or that America is
driving toward a North Korean solution
which of course is absolute nonsense
so Trump brought the family of otto
warmbier you remember warmbier was a
University of Virginia student who was
tortured and murdered by the North
Korean regime he brought their family
but the clip of the night the one that
actually made all the headlines was him
talking about a North Korean refugee
this is clip 11 who was attempting to
escape North Korea and and what he had
to go through in order to reach freedom
sung ho travel thousands of miles on
crutches all across China and Southeast
Asia to freedom most of his family
followed his father was caught trying to
escape and was tortured to death today
he lives in Seoul where he rescues other
defectors and broadcasts into North
Korea what the regime fears most the
truth today he has a new leg but somehow
I understand you still keep those old
crutches as a reminder of how far you've
come your great sacrifice is an
inspiration to us all please thank you
some ho story is a testament to the
yearning of every human soul to live in
freedom yeah that last line is direct
from the George W Bush speech this idea
that every human soul your inste live in
freedom I actually disagree with that I
think there are a lot of human beings
who desire sanctity over freedom for
example purity over freedom this is
obviously true in large swaths of the
Islamic world but that image of this
young North Korean lifting his crutches
the ones that he used to walk thousands
of miles out of North Korea is an
amazing amazing image and it's a
reminder of what America is now that's
what this speech really was last night
that's not the way the Democrats and the
media treated it the way the Democrats
in the media treated it was as though it
was the worst thing that they had ever
seen it was just terrible terrible so
you can see the Democrats for example
booed president Trump when he started
talking about the dangers of chain
migration under the current broken
system a single immigrant can bring in
virtually unlimited numbers of distant
relatives under our plan we focus on the
immediate family by limiting
sponsorships to spouses and minor
children okay you can hear them booing
there the worst moment of course is luis
Gutierrez the representative who
actually fled the State of the Union
when people started chanting USA you can
see that here this Capitol this living
monument this is the monument to the
American people
they can see there's Gutierrez and he's
out
so you scoots here as can't deal with
people chanting USA and he leaves yeah
good look for the Democrats there this
is what the Democrats refuse to
acknowledge is that Trump can use
unifying language I want to use his
unifying language you should cheer and
when he doesn't you should boo but
instead they just decided boom all the
way through in a second we are going to
get to all the Democratic responses we
can get to Joe Kennedy the third we're
gonna get to Bernie Sanders we're gonna
get to the media fallout which is just
insipid and insane but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
1-800 flowers calm well if you even want
to send condolence flowers to a Democrat
after last night or Valentine's Day is
coming up and you actually want to send
in you want to send flowers to a loved
one now is the time 1-800 flowers calm
is your answer right now when you order
early you get 12 multicolored roses for
only $19.99 I know what you're gonna do
you're just gonna wait until Valentine's
Day and then you're gonna be like oh no
I didn't get my wife anything I didn't
get my girlfriend anything and then
you're gonna go down to the gas station
you're gonna pick up some bad sushi and
you're gonna stamp a heart on it and say
happy Valentine's Day
don't be that guy instead right now
while you're listening just go to your
computer go to 1-800 flowers calm and
get 12 multicolored roses for just
$19.99 or double it to 24 multi colored
roses for only $10 more it's a great
offer twelve multi colored Rosie in 1999
double it for ten bucks more they are
shipped at their peak they're picked at
their peak shipped overnight to ensure
freshness and her amazement and when it
comes to Valentine's don't settle for
anything less than America's leading
rose authority at 1-800 flowers calm
again that special deal for the 1999 for
the for the dozen roses in 24 and 24
multi colored roses for 10 bucks or more
go to 1-800 flowers calm click the radio
icon in the corner enter promo code at
Shapiro again that's one eight hundred
flowers that con make sure you enter
that promo code Shapiro so you get the
discount and again they are the freshest
flowers shipped overnight to you I
promise the person you send them to will
love them and appreciate them just as
they love and appreciate you so 1-800
flowers calm and use that promo code
Shapiro okay so we'll get to let's go to
the media response first and then we'll
get to the actual Democratic responses
to the State of the Union so number one
you can see how insane this made the
Democrat so Cory Booker Democratic
senator who who cried tears of Rage
tears of Rage Lee raged so much rage
from Cory Booker oh so he was asked
specifically about the State of the
Union and he says that it was ugly and
fear-mongering I just want to
ask a question I showed you a lot of
clips did you see anything there that
smacked of ugly fear-mongering - you
ugly for your money because that's not
what I saw last night I'm not sure what
speech cory booker was watching except
that he has on his his tears of rage
glasses and so all he could see was
through those tears of rage evil and
horror here's a here's senator Booker
and here's a guy that used religion
tonight to divide here's a guy that used
patriotism whenever somebody pulls out
patriotism use it as a way to condemn
other people for their patriotic acts
how they choose to exhibit their
Patriots is that's a divisive way of
going about it
and so the raw meat was ugly and then
the appeals to fear-mongering are using
ms-13 as a way to cast a shadow around
millions of Americans who are looking
for a full recognition of their
citizenship rights there are so many
examples of this that we're just painful
okay so again you know cory booker
saying all this stuff is just nonsense
there there's really no excuse for him
to say this because i just didn't see it
last night and maybe maybe I missed it
but that's not what I saw Chris Matthews
did the same thing on MSNBC I gets up I
would say fake talk about comes there
was a show and then does that say the
Union was so terrible is worse than mine
yelled at my interns so listen I
sexually harassed to help these garbage
get up come in here don't even shower
and I have to watch this nonsense just
awful
Chris Matthews I'm it go it had a lot of
particular things that weren't rough and
then it took a turn halfway through it
it almost got ugly very tough about
saying immigrants are basically killers
ma ms-13 beginning a discussion about
immigration in the country of immigrants
with crime and that was this way of
opening up the discussion like I'm
protecting us from criminal elements I
think that got very ugly about that
point I'm very ugly they mentions ms-13
is though it's not a problem in the
United States again Trump did not label
all immigrants ms-13 he said he wanted
to let 1.8 million illegal immigrants
remain in the country as also when he
got to more media response we're going
to get to everything related to the
Democratic responses which were really I
thought Joe Kennedy's particularly was
quite terrible
we'll get to all of that but first
you're going to have to go over to Daley
wired comments
crowd $9.99 a month gets you your
subscription that comes along with the
rest of this show live the rest of
Andrew Clemons show live Michael Moses
show live you watch our live coverage
last night yet see how great those guys
are and you can get their shows live in
their complete horror when you go over
to Daily wire comm and buy a
subscription for $9.99 a month or get
the annual subscription get all of those
things and you can get these leftist
tiers higher are called tumblers which
we were all using on set last night
they replenish they revitalize they make
you young once more the leftist here's
hot are called tumblers to get those for
$99 a year along with the annual
subscription so all of that is available
there if you want to listen later iTunes
SoundCloud YouTube please subscribe to
all those channels and leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
so it was just what you would expect
from from the media suggesting that this
was the worst speech ever I thought the
most hilarious thing was democracy dies
in darkness the Washington Post they ran
an original headline and the original
headline said a call for bipartisanship
and as a picture of Trump speaking and
then they got ratioed so being ratio and
on Twitter means that you have more
comments on your tweet then you have
retweets on your tweet say something
like 3,000 comments because a bunch of
Democrats said no that's terrible Trump
didn't deliver a message of unity it
wasn't a call for bipartisanship it was
mean it was cruel it was ugly so what do
they do well those brave people the
democracy dies in darkness they they
they switch to that one so now instead
of is announces a new American moment
Trump adopts a gentler approach so
rallies fiery Barb's give way to
traditional formality in speech gridded
realities of governing and politics of
weight after higher minded talk right
all those headlines change go back to
the original page for just a second the
original headlines say look at that a
call for bipartisan Trump delivers
message of unity president highlights
military economy and then below that it
says a chance to act presidential II at
least for a night right so they just
shifted every headline so that it's
nasty every single headline change
because people ratioed them on Twitter
and then we're supposed to believe the
media don't have a bias of course the
media have a bias the good news is that
when it comes to the State of the Union
address so many more people watch it
then read about it the next day that it
doesn't really matter very much but it
just shows you the insane level of bias
now the Democrats tried to respond the
the response to the State of the Union
is almost invariably terrible there has
never been a very good response to the
State of the Union
Democrats trotted out Joe Kennedy the
third who of course is famous for being
a Kennedy not for actually accomplishing
anything first of all very very bad move
to have a Kennedy speak in front of a
broken car right just do a car with the
hood open that's just a bad way to start
a speech by a Kennedy descendant they
have a bad history with cars that have
been submerged in water for example
other things to point out you'll see as
Joe Kennedy speaks that he was
supposedly drooling but he used actually
like a vat of chapstick and so his mouth
is shiny while he gives this speech
unfortunately he didn't have the full-on
Kennedy mayor Quimby from The Simpsons
accent because that would have made it
much more amusing but he was his radical
after
as possible to be he decided to respond
to Trump not by saying you know
President Trump said a lot of nice
things like these people write their
speeches before they actually see
Trump's so what they should have said is
they should have said listen if I were
democrat here's what I would say
president crimson a lot of nice things
about the economy all that's wonderful
we all want to see the economy grow he
has not put us on a path to sustainable
growth here the reasons why also the
president talked a lot about unity and
bringing the country together but no one
who's been more divisive than this
president and then I would go down the
list of all the terrible divisive things
the President Trump has supposedly done
and said when I point out that there is
a character flaw in the modern
Republican Party that allows for this
sort of thing right you want to make the
argument on character grounds because
people vote on character grounds instead
Democrats are trapped in this
intersectionality nonsense and so
instead of going after Trump for all the
things he said they decided they have to
stand up for all these intersectional
groups so here is here is the Joe
Kennedy pandering the me2 movement and
the hack crowd and pandering to
black lives matter a group that is
extraordinarily radical here here is
America we carry that story on our
shoulders he's such a bad speaker well
you swarmed Washington last year to
ensure that no parent has to worry if
they can afford to save their child's
life you proudly marched together last
weekend thousands deep on the streets of
Las Vegas in Philadelphia and Nashville
you set high atop your mom's shoulders
and held a sign that read build a wall
and my generation will tear it down
you bravely say me to you steadfastly
say black lives matter I mean this is
deeply radical stuff he's not gonna
speak her first of all so the idea that
this guy can speak is just not true
every phrase is punctuated by a short
gap to demonstrate emotion but it just
doesn't work it's not good in any real
sense that line builds a wall in my
generation will tear it down as an
insane line that's an insane line I mean
Dennis Prager pointed this out last
night during our watch party
he said that's basically Democrats
saying we don't want borders at all
right no walls at all transnationalism
at its finest okay try that in America
and see how long that lasts
you know how quickly America will be
swamped by people who want to come here
and may not share our values pretty damn
quickly we're a very wealthy country
it's a pretty astonishing statement
builds a wall in our generation will
tear it down I certainly hope not
you know I'd like to tell you if that's
true that I'd like to know whether the
Kennedy family compound has walls around
it whether those ought to be torn down
too but he says you bravely say me to
you steadfastly say black lives matter
these are just slogans they're just
slogans because he doesn't explain how
these movements are good or what they're
doing or why he would support them and
then he and then he you know launched
into his character attack on on trumpet
it was it was really weak stuff it would
it would be easy to dismiss this past
year as chaos partisanship as politics
but it's far far bigger than that this
administration isn't just targeting the
laws that protect us they're targeting
the very idea that we are all worthy of
protection okay again no he's not in
fact Trump was the one who was saying
that Americans are worthy of protection
it's you who are saying that we're gonna
tear down the walls that prevent people
from entering the country illegally and
then of course Kennedy address dreamers
directly in Spanish and then he said
you're part of our story we'll fight for
you and we will not walk away Trump was
saying in his speech we will fight for
Americans and Kennedy was saying in his
speech will fight for everyone who's
outside the country basically that is
not a good look we're gonna fight also
for the most radical elements of
American society pretty astonishing that
this is what Democrats choose to trot
forward with if they think that they can
defeat Trump with this sort of
radicalism I'm not sure that that's the
case I think that they are much better
off running somebody who at least
purports to unify the country as opposed
to continuing the polarization of
intersectional politics the Barack Obama
pursuit this is why Bernie Sanders his
response was probably better I mean it
was filled with the usual stupidities
but it's this is I think even Bernie
Sanders looked tired last night I mean
Sanders gave a response and Sanders
always looks tired because he's a
thousand years old and did not have his
proper share of pudding last night
before he gave his State of the Union
response address he should have been
focusing as I say on character issues
and also on 1% it's sustainable growth
and all the rest of this but he has to
just go down that the progressive
talking points list instead I mean it
was Trump tonight and it was pretty
obvious is Trump tonight from Sanders
his response in Trump Sanders spends
time ripping on Trump for not talking
about climate change can when you look
at the polls climate change is like
number 11 number 13 on Americans list of
concerns but that's where Bernie Sanders
chooses to go now I don't understand how
a President of the United States can
give a State of the Union speech and not
mention climate change No mr. Trump
climate change is not a hoax it is a
reality which is causing devastating
harm all over our country and all over
the world and you are dead wrong when
you appoint administrators at the EPA
and other agencies were trying to
decimate environmental protection rules
and slow down the transition to
sustainable and it's good luck with this
I mean first of all him looking like
he's appearing on a c-span callin unit
in the middle of the State of the Union
response is not a good look it was Trump
tonight this was the best night that
Trump has had in a very long time if
from could sustain it then yet I'd be
optimistic for 2018 and 2020 I highly
doubt that it will be sustained just
because that has not been the pattern
thus far but it was there's no question
was a good night for Trump is a bad
night for Democrats and we'll see if
they continue to shoot themselves in the
foot Democrats really shot themselves in
the foot last night even more than Trump
won himself a victory okay we're gonna
get two things I like and things I hate
so let's just jump right in there so
time for a quick thing I like so we've
been doing buck this week so he did
Brahmas a couple of weeks ago this week
is bath this of course very famous piece
that you will all know this is Bostick
and feud which you will remember from
Fantasia as well as every horror movie
ever
[Music]
so this is pretty fantastic piece
obviously it was written maybe as early
as 1700 for one Bach was still as teens
there's some people who say that maybe
was was you know dated in the in the
night in the 1740s in any case it was
only really rediscovered in the 1800s
and Felix Mendelssohn a great composer
in his own right will have to do a week
of Mendelssohn music so I loved
Mendelssohn's music we will the it was
his rediscovering the 1800s and and
recaptured so much of Western thought is
involved in rediscovery of old ideas and
renewal of those old ideas and that is
true in politics as well as in music one
of the the problems with modern music is
that we've just essentially abandoned
all the old ideas about tonality and
form and in the developed natural ear
and all the rest of us instead we've
decided to focus in on what is most
convenient we focused in on energy in
the pop sphere or we focused in on
abstruse nonsense in the classical
sphere and when you listen to great
classical music of the past there's a
reason it has driving power and that's
because it resonates with the human soul
in a way the modern music simply doesn't
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate it's a number one thing I hate trey
gowdy is apparently leaving the house
that was announced just minutes ago the
representative from from South Carolina
says that he is leaving Congress this
would make another house chair who's
leaving his committee it looks like
Republicans in the House are foreseeing
a democratic wave in 2018 we will see if
they are right or if they are not Gowdy
was one of the best prosecutors in in
Congress he was a terrific questioner
when it came to the Oversight Committee
it's a sad thing to see him go he says
gonna go back to his his practice of law
a good public servant is trey Gowdy and
it says that's that's too bad to see him
go in other news Hillary Clinton last
night I mean talk about just a document
on me in the middle of the State of the
Union address or right before it she
dumped a giant Facebook post essentially
apologizing for protecting campaign
subordinate who is sexually preying on
young women so she she waited until the
middle of the State of the Union dump
and I wonder why she was so unpopular
and lost a president Trump I just can't
believe it
she actually will launch into a 1,500
word Facebook post just minutes before
Trump's State of the Union address she
said
he needed to be punished he's talking
about that it burns Strider her faith
advisor she says he needed to be
punished change his behavior and
understand why his actions were wrong
the young woman needed to be able to
thrive and feel safe I thought both
could happen without losing his job but
then she suggested that she made a
mistake doing that says I've been given
a second chance that given them to
others I want to continue to believe in
them but she says the second chance was
squandered and she said she was dismayed
by the allegations of sexual harassment
again she is just awful I mean Hillary
Clinton is just awful at everything and
her awfulness extends to launching
complete disavowal essentially of her me
to moment in the middle of the State of
the Union address in an attempt to bury
it under under Trump's big shining hour
so we will be back here tomorrow with
all the fallout we will see if the the
memo is released the famous House
Intelligence memos released that's
apparently on the brink of release we'll
talk about that i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018